-Our next guest is an Emmy-
and Tony Award-winning actor
you know from his work on "Monk"
and "The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel."
He stars in "Mr. Monk's
Last Case: A Monk Movie,"
which premieres
December 8th on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-We hired you to write
about your career
as a police detective.
You solved 140 homicides.
That's the story we paid for.
Not this.
Oh, here in Chapter 4,
you have two paragraphs
about the suspect
and seven, eight, nine pages
about his vacuum cleaner.
-We had the same vacuum cleaner,
the exact same model.
What are the odds of that?
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Tony Shalhoub!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Thank you. Wow.
It's been a while,
but it's great to be here.
-It's great to have you here.
I was very happy to see you.
You are a
Green Bay Packers fan.
-Oh, indeed.
-There was a
Sunday Night Football game.
-Yes, against the
Kansas City Swifts -- Chiefs.
-The Kansas City Swifts.
Well, I was going to say,
you were on the sidelines.
-There I am, yeah.
-And it must have been
a rare case
where nobody cared
about you at all.
-It was.
It was -- My thunder
was not only stolen
but actually sent out
into the stratosphere.
Yeah.
-Also, I want to note,
she's always in, like,
a very warm box seat,
and you're just on the field.
-No, no.
[ Laughs ]
No, actually,
that was just a pre-game.
-Oh, oh.
-I actually was in a box, too.
Do you know what's funny?
Everyone, you know, asked me,
"Are you going to see
Taylor Swift?
Did you see Taylor?"
As if, like, there's one box,
you know, in the stadium.
You know,
and I was really disa--
I was disappointed I didn't,
because she is --
I mean, she is such
an enormous "Monk" fan.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
-Everybody knows that, yeah.
That would have been huge.
-It would have been great,
so great for her.
-I think I've heard her say
almost half her songs
are actually about "Monk."
-Subliminally, yes.
-You like watching football,
but you also like
not just what's happening
on the field.
You're kind of obsessed
with what the coaches
are doing on the sidelines.
-Yeah, you know, I have this --
I love games.
You know, of course,
I'm obsessed with the Packers.
I'm from Green Bay.
But, you know,
and I watch other games.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, somebody from Green Bay.
-That -- By the way,
I've been to Green Bay.
That might be half of them.
-Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, but there's just
a few things
about it's televised,
watching games on TV.
I mean, being there
live is fantastic,
but on TV, there's just one --
There's one thing
that really drives me insane.
You know, when the cameras
are, you know,
panning the sideline,
and then, you know,
they -- Do you mind?
-Yeah.
-They go, they shoot the coach,
and the coach is,
like, doing this.
It's like...
-Yeah, he holds, like, a
clipboard in front of his face.
-Yeah, what is that?
-Yeah.
-This is -- What is that?
-It's like the
"Home Alone neighbor.
Not the "Home Alone."
What is it?
"Home Improvement."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know.
I mean, you know,
God bless the coaches.
They got to do
what they got to do,
but let's just move the camera
somewhere else, you know?
-If you want to show us their
mouth, we'll put them on TV,
but, otherwise,
we don't want to look at it.
-Yeah. Or maybe they --
coaches could just get --
You know,
they have these headsets.
Couldn't they just get
a little round disc
on the end of the mic,
so they can just talk and --
-Yeah, just say what they want.
You're right. The disc.
Why aren't they doing the disc?
That's bad. Yeah, you're right.
This is very exciting.
This is 14 years
since "Monk" ended,
and it ended well --
eight wonderful seasons.
You were very happy
with how it resolved itself.
-Yeah, we had a two-part finale.
You know, we really
were proud of that.
It was -- You know, we --
Monk solves the case
of his wife's murder, finally.
And the ratings
were really good.
And so, you know,
there wasn't a big incentive
to revisit this character.
And then -- Well, then
the pandemic happened,
and we did this public-service
announcement for Peacock,
and, you know,
talking about being safe
and wearing masks
and all that.
And, all of a sudden,
the response
to that public-service
announcement was huge.
And then we -- the writers
and the network said,
"Hey, let's try a 'Monk' movie."
-I mean, it's weird
and also fitting
that the pandemic
sort of brought it about,
because, of course, Monk
was this character with OCD,
a character with high anxiety.
And we sort of all became
more like Monk.
-Right.
-For basically two years,
we all sort of
Monked out a little bit.
-Yeah. And that's kind of
what the --
That's sort of laced into
the plot of our movie, you know,
the fact that he has gotten
knocked back on his heels way,
way -- He's regressed.
He's now worse than he was when
we first met him, in the pilot.
And -- But also that
the world has changed,
and he doesn't look quite
so neurotic anymore.
-Oh, well, that's good.
Yeah, so he's worse,
but so are the rest of us.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
Your beautiful, talented wife,
Brooke, was the editor
in the clip we showed.
And --
-Yeah, she's the publisher.
-The publisher. Excuse me.
-Yes.
-But she's also --
I was not aware
she has been
on "Monk" multiple times,
but as multiple
different characters.
-Yes. Never played
the same character twice.
-This shows
Brooke's incredible range.
Here she was there.
-Oh, the crazy cat lady.
-Yep. I was going to say.
If you had asked me to guess
the name of the character,
I would have said that.
Also did
some law-enforcement work.
-Right.
-Here she is --
Here's the clip we just saw
of her as the publisher.
-Right.
-Who was she here?
-Oh, this was one of
the roles --
She did a very dramatic role
where a son of hers
is kidnapped or something, and
--
I can't remember the plot.
And -- Sorry.
And, yeah, it's a very, very
moving and a dramatic role.
-And then here she is as
a flight attendant.
Excuse me.
-Yeah, a flight attendant.
Right. She plays this stewardess
who has been
sober for many years, and then,
by the end of the flight,
she's drinking out
of the little bottle.
-It really is.
She's a jack-of-all-trades.
-Yeah.
-It's very impressive.
-She's the transforming actor.
-I have more to ask about her
and more to ask about you.
We're going to be right back
with Tony after this.